thank you david for letting us know
we're live we love our david here if you
can find the allen wrench we got a
special guest here today
chief bitcoin
that's actually your title yes and your
entire mo is bitcoin crypto uh you work
that as a fundamental analyst hedge fund
private and
you got strong foreign you got some
stuff to say about uh dorsey yesterday
with twitter
you even uh said you got to get on
twitch which is maybe we can talk about
that
um but we've got a lot to talk about we
got we got a speed run i'll give you
names of people in your world i'm
curious to know what your opinion is
going to be on them some tells me you're
not the kind of person that's going to
be safe
we have a friend back there a mexican
adam sosnick manny soto is in the house
we have a wager to see who's got better
game
one of these days when you guys go out i
got to get the report on what happens
our analyst gerard will go with you
and he may just school both of you by
the time it's over yeah and then we have
also my brother-in-law
imani siamak sabet imani in the house
see ya in the house if you're in a
persian community you know that last
name that is a legendary last name
i did see some videos
by the way you said that to me his dad's
a legend
so today for our viewers if you're
interested in crypto listen up today's
the day right this we're gonna go
[Music]
yeah so we got a lot of stuff to get
into so before we get into it before we
get into it kurt why don't you tell
everybody your background so people know
sure uh maybe skip the part about you
and your wife mma ufc all that stuff but
specific to crypto uh so
2012 i was a um
i was a business owner i owned a
printing company okay i was also big
into the sound money and the fed
community and all of that in chicago
i had a guy come to me and say hey man i
need some posters printed can i pay you
in bitcoin i said i don't know what the
hell bitcoin is he tells me well it's
kind of like video game money i said
okay well that that's whatever it was
like a fifty dollar jobs was like that's
fine it doesn't matter pay me a bitcoin
well that brought me the the first step
down the rabbit hole and uh by the end
of the next year i was running a small
mining operation and doing all kinds of
things so 2013 to 15.
i was big in the infrastructure space i
wanted to figure out like how does
bitcoin work but by the way when he gave
you that 50 bitcoin what was bitcoin in
100 bucks yeah not even i think it was a
little less yeah so almost like a full
bitcoin at 50 bucks 75 bucks if i recall
i got a little more than one bitcoin if
i recall okay cool for a little stack of
posts today it's what 55k yeah the only
reason i know what price it was is
because i bought bitcoin in 2012 i told
this story before at a libertarian
convention a guy talked about i was like
yeah i love this and the fed screw fiat
currency i bought 100 bitcoin for a
thousand bucks it went down to 900 bucks
next week i was like ah this is a scam
and i pulled it all out i lost 100 bucks
i owned 10 big i own 10 bitcoin and 100
bucks each
yeah that's my bitcoin story anyway so
yeah i mean long story short got
involved in an infrastructure i wanted
to um i was a
big fan of using bitcoin as cash using
it in the economy i i believed fully in
disrupting
business use cases so everybody wants to
talk about the finance aspect like hold
get rich all of that for me it was like
okay well what what inefficient data
silos and all this different stuff is
out there that we can disrupt so for me
i was getting into development like
wallet development all these different
things i i wanted to go that direction
and then what i like to call the bitcoin
civil war started
around 2015 this talk about whether or
not bitcoin should be used as a business
tool or whether it is just simply a
savings or an investment technology
bitcoin civil war absolutely okay so who
is going against who so if it's north
and south what's the
who's the enemy here
the most basic way to put it is small
blockers versus big blockers
on the small blocker side you have uh
block stream lightning labs they're
they're primarily funded by a group
called digital currency group which is a
incubator owned by mastercard ventures
and they believe that bitcoin is a
an investment tool only buy it hold it
that's it if you want to use it maybe
use lightning network whether or not it
works is you know irrelevant because
it's primarily an investment technology
on the big blocker side
there's actually a couple factions of
big blockers that all kind of hate each
other too but there's the the bitcoin
cash community and bitcoin sv community
i'm i'm a bitcoin sv guy
um that at the time was uh roger ver
uh guys like craig wright bitcoin
unlimited um in 2015 the big group was
bitcoin xt so a lot of these people are
like hey we'll just create a bitcoin
implementation that allows miners to to
make a change uh when whenever they feel
like if there's more traffic they can
raise the block size and and just
go that direction like let's let's keep
fees predictable let's use bitcoin as
cash
and that became an increasingly
unpopular opinion and and the reason is
is because people just kept getting
richer by doing nothing and if you're
getting rich doing nothing what's your
incentive to maybe rock the boat to
maybe pursue some other avenue and i get
that but the problem is is all the
disruptive stuff happens when people
actually disrupt business and and that's
really what i want to see bitcoin do and
and it really hasn't done that yet even
all the other blockchains that exist
today because ethereum is the one that's
going to do it no no it absolutely is
not ethereum is
no doubt 100 percent not a war on people
yeah
so so why to me here's my question maybe
help us understand the following for
some folks that don't follow it so uh
you know in religion you'll have um
jews will say christianity you know
they're really jews jesus was a jew so
you guys kind of took it and came out
with this niv and then changed the whole
thing
you know it's really judaism 2. right
and then christians will say well lds
you know you took a joseph smith from
vermont and you took this and you
created lds and you guys went and out of
chicago eventually ended up in utah
brigham young et cetera et cetera
seven day all this stuff that you hear
about right muslim baha'i so
what
it almost sounds like in the crypto
community there is religions right you
got
folks like pomp who will swear by
bitcoin and nothing else like literally
nothing else the other day i was on uh
is it natalie burnell who is a very
eloquent i was on her podcast and we
were speaking she is strictly bitcoin
not ethereum not
nothing else and then there's guys that
dabble on everything and diversify and
there's guys that just can't stand
bitcoin why don't you explain to us what
these different religions within crypto
are
uh first of all i i love the religious
analogy it's one that i use all the time
so it's often you know trying to figure
out
the israel-palestine issue right like
we'll we'll never see those two groups
likely come to an agreement on oh okay
we all agree this is all gonna work not
gonna happen but
the thing with bitcoin and that people
don't understand is that bitcoin is
capable
of being everything to everyone and and
that's really how it was designed it was
designed
fundamentally to replace the internet we
don't have 10 000 internets we have one
internet it is a fixed protocol that
people can build on in above around but
you know the internet's going to be
there so you can build your business
based on knowing that the internet is
going to be the same in five years and
10 years whatever the these are at least
the assumptions that we make the problem
with all these different protocols with
ethereum is a great example ethereum
hardworks basically once every year has
a very deep and fundamental protocol
change which means everybody needs to
retool everything everybody needs to
reissue tokens they need to reissue the
apps that they make they need to reissue
these smart contracts basically breaks
everything and then at the end of the
day ethereum is only really capable of
about 15 transactions per second
globally
which is nothing this is essentially
zero throughput 15 transactions per
second globally correct okay got it visa
for example is good for about 50 000 per
second per second so so let me ask you
this does ethereum have the ability to
improve that or that's the limit like
they claim to uh and they're about two
and a half years behind on their road
map saying that they absolutely will but
i i think it's i think it's a big meme i
think they want to continue to pump
valuations it's like tesla it's like hey
man these trucks are coming out you know
in 2019 no they're coming in 2012 well
okay it's 20 21 we'll probably get them
by 2020. but you look at tesla's now
trillion dollar evaluations so
should they be you have to know this
from my end the one thing you need to
know about this group i don't know about
him but i'm not we're i'm not tied to a
group i'm just simply asking a question
to get smarter right so to me when you
talk to the metaverse community or the
uh nft community they'll say you know i
don't know ethereum's got 10 million
coins i don't know the exact number what
it is but give or take is what i hear
it's it's actually
endless so so ethereum is emitted
constantly forever so there is no supply
cap on ethereum it exists specifically
to launch smart contracts that are
that's the key right so the smart
contract is what i love about ethereum
personally like so much of this is
currency and we get into like the the
speculative investment because so much
money is being made and lost but you
said it before it's really technology
that people don't understand the
blockchain specifically is the future of
all commerce so but what people don't
understand is that bitcoin was always
capable of smart contracts and smart
contracts that are more powerful than
ethereum smart contracts ethereum is
limited by it's a very fundamentally
different
uh
design they use a gas model and and this
is why the fees are astronomical
and all this stuff so
in bitcoin
nodes are competitive whereas so every
node in ethereum needs to cross every
threshold together so the network is
only as fast as the weakest node in the
network which in my opinion it's an
altruistic system which in my opinion is
garbage you should never build
a network that is based on altruism so
everybody's trying to
placate everyone have it have it so that
everyone can run nodes this is why they
want to switch to proof of stake like
well we'll get more people to run more
nodes that'll be good and i think the
exact opposite i would rather have 10
people who are ruthless and really
really want to scale really want to
disrupt
everything and are willing to do
anything to make that possible and
that's how bitcoin's designed bitcoin
uses what's called the utxo model
which allows them to parallelize and
compete so rather than having one chain
that is is jumping to each block you
have maybe hundreds maybe thousands of
nodes that are competing to build the
best block and they want to orphan
everybody else they want to force
everybody to go their direction because
they're the best who's this this is any
one of them this is the way the bitcoin
protocol is designed so so
right now it could be anybody and it
could change on a dime in fact this is
why we've seen you know these fiefdoms
grow up in bitcoin and then crash down
and it's because it's like look man i'm
just better than you and if you can't
keep up if you cannot be better than me
you lose and you should lose and that's
what makes bitcoin great go back to
ethereum so when you talk about the i
brought up the nfts half the nfts that
are being bought they're being bought
through ethereum that's what i keep
hearing about the fact that people are
buying nfts through ethereum correct but
solano's all these other guys are coming
they can buy nfts through right so is
that something where if
we know nfts are not going away we know
there's going to be a fall you know the
rise in the fall just similar to the
stock market people are getting prepared
for it but if we know nft is going to be
around we know meta's not going away
it's here right that's not like a maybe
we're gonna do it the moment zuck said
that everybody started googling meta
checking what that is all about right
so isn't that a solid argument for the
ethereum community to say
look we understand that you said what 50
per second or 15 15. 15 per second
eventually we're going to figure this
out just like tesla eventually figured
it out we're going to figure it out so
my follow-up to that would be two
questions for you to answer is
if ethereum does figure it out
okay i don't know what the numbers were
did they get to 5 000 10 000 or 50 000
at visas level i don't know but if they
do would they be the cream of the crop
coin out there if they do figure it out
i mean that i think that if is
impossible i i would i would put the if
at
nearing zero percent but if they did if
they did
well sure i mean whoever whoever can be
the most disruptive and bring on the
most people to do the most business with
the least amount of friction should
absolutely win
but i don't think ethereum has any of
those things what about uh solana you
hear that sort of replacing the ethereum
i really don't like solana either i i
think solana solana is a really really
great implementation of a really bad
protocol it's essentially just
uh a bunch of good stuff about ethereum
and and some good stuff about bitcoin
but they've missed the boat on a lot of
things what they do have is really great
software developers so the ux and all of
this stuff is excellent but at a
protocol level it can't scale either it
hits a scale ceiling that means it needs
to be fundamentally re-engineered from
the ground up and that's not something
for example that we can do with the
internet we can't just be like all right
guys so i know we went down this path
and we're hitting a wall here we need to
shut the internet off for 90 days while
we relaunch and retool right that's
that's not going to work for the world
and that's nice i believe it was it was
shut the internet down for 15 days to
slow the spread i believe
it was yeah that worked really well too
so so i i so then this leads me to a
question for you are you going to a
place where you're saying
these are the two three four five coins
that could potentially dot dot are there
those coins out there in my opinion so
if you look at bitcoin sv bitcoin sv is
the only
blockchain right now that has all
parameters are open and they are they
are minor settings so each node can
compete right now there is no protocol
what is the node i'm sorry so a node is
a computer that validates transactions
and writes transactions to the
blockchain so if you have a
soft wallet on on your phone and you
send let's say you're using exodus and
you send a bitcoin transaction that is
being broadcast to
nodes mining mining computers that that
will write your transaction to the
ledger so those are the nodes right now
in in btc bitcoin they are not allowed
to attempt to build a block bigger than
one megabyte that's it
that's that's the swim lanes that have
been decided by software developers
whose names you don't know and who you
do not know how to position that's what
bothers me a little bit about bitcoin
the the anonymity look i understand why
people who made billions and billions of
dollars would not want anybody to know
that they had billions of billions of
dollars sure but
you find out there's some you know like
finding out people like calvin ayer and
you know some people that are really
really
let me just get right to it i mean like
satoshi does he exist does he not exist
does
is it a real person is it amalgamation
and if you can't know who's controlling
this why should you invest anything in
it well and that's the thing i mean it's
a zeitgeist right it's it's the exact
same thing with
this is the word of the day that's a
word of his life
pots and pans
so you can tell gerard prepared that
question for the day
i mean
let's let's go back to the religious
analogy like i mean you never met jesus
why go to church on sunday you know it's
there's there's an aspect of faith to
all of these things including money in
general are you comparing satoshi
nakamoto to jesus i i think there's a
lot of really applicable analogies there
really absolutely 100
well i mean it's it's it's somebody
people people disagree whether or not
like who he is whether it's one person
or many uh you know what was he in fact
there's there's all kinds of people on
the internet what was it an ai from the
future has he come back you know like he
was jewish though for sure
satoshi or jesus
so jesus is from the tribe of judah and
yes it's very much to help adam
understand better you could say satoshi
is more like biden you never know where
he is
you know just to help you you know he's
making peace
in my opinion satoshi nakamoto is an
australian man who is a i'm i'm a firm
believer that craig wright is the
primary architect of bitcoin i believe
he wrote the white paper
and you just pissed a lot of people oh i
know this is the single most right this
is the most unpopular thing in fact i
guarantee you're lighting up right now
with ah this guy's a scammer kick them
out your reputation's done
craig wright um so craig wright is right
now in in miami there's a lawsuit going
on right now
the largest private lawsuit of all time
there's about 160 billion dollars being
asked they're saying that they're saying
that it's the trial of the century it
was oj
now it's satoshi do you know who started
calling it the trial of the century
jazlyn maxwell's lawyers
when you say miami there's art basel
going on this week it's a big deal
there's a lot of nft crypto stuff going
on at the art basel art obviously then
there's the um
defy conference going on near the
airport is that why craig writes in town
is that why no no wright is in town at
federal court he is likely at the milky
d ferguson federal court building right
now the jury is actually deliberating
the case is over and the jury is
currently deliberating we're actually
expecting a verdict today but it's a
civilization it's a civil suit not a
criminal it is a civil suit between the
estate of dave clyman which which says
that dave was 50 of of the satoshi
nakamoto team and then craig wright says
absolutely he was not a business partner
in any regard he was my dear friend he
did help me edit the white paper but he
always helped me out at white papers he
was essentially a contractor who was
also a friend but bitcoin was my idea
i'm the architect of it he helped me
with some of the trimmings and and i'm
happy to deal with that but but he does
not get 50 of of my my invention you
interviewed chris i did did you i did
and by the way yeah yeah we had a great
time together so it's a phenomenal
conversation i just i enjoy talking to
him but i got to tell you afterwards
after interviewing craig wright there's
only been about well i can't say that
he's probably in the top 10 interviews
that i got the most dms emails twice
people pissed off
about having craig right on so go back
into why you think it is craig rock
because there's a lot of different names
that you hear about why why him sure so
this really should be prefaced with the
bitcoin civil war this is this is why
this is not this is not just a cultural
disagreement thing this is this is
israel versus palestine kind of stuff
sunni shia
exactly never gonna agree on anything
exactly so the the reason that i think
it's craig wright first of all is that
every other potential candidate makes
absolutely zero sense so people bring up
like nick zabo or they bring up uh even
hal finney how finney what's up with
that how finney's a very cool guy he's a
very talented software engineer he
fundamentally disagreed with satoshi in
public i mean you can read their
conversations hal finney didn't
understand bitcoin he was a software
engineer and very talented and satoshi
gave him software work to do none of
this is contentious but hal never
understood bitcoin he argued with
satoshi about how it should be
engineered so satoshi does exist satoshi
absolutely exists he exists yes also dan
pena is full of [ __ ] first time ever
first time ever he does dan pena dan
paid ya
first time he's been right about
literally everything i've always i like
dan pena but but i i think he's gonna
want to vote here
so so the other guys like they look at
bitcoin and they say ah it's got
security problems everybody would need
to run a node it can't scale and satoshi
always argued with these guys no no no
it can scale no you do not need to run a
node only people that are trying to mine
coins need to run a node so there's this
big disagreement on all these
definitions in bitcoin so we can't even
get past the basic presuppositions of
what is bitcoin how is bitcoin all of
that this this sounds like an iron sword
this is this has been from social
network day one so the very first
response when satoshi put the white
paper out and said hi i'm satoshi i've
solved the double spend problem here's
the bitcoin white paper the first guy
came out to say well here's why it
doesn't work and they have this this
rant that is very typical even in social
media today well it can't scale because
everyone would need to run a node and
then it would have this problem and then
you can't propagate blocks and blah blah
blah and satoshi basically gave the big
blocker version this is the side of
bitcoin that i fall on of saying no
absolutely not bitcoin could do
visa level transactions today with
existing hardware
and he explained the basics on how but
he didn't go really deeply into it he
said but nonetheless the network hasn't
even launched yet but don't worry nodes
can consolidate into commercial
operations where everyone connects into
what is essentially what we know today
as a mining pool and describes out
all the ways that it can scale and how
it should work and people
started to fight immediately so the very
first conversation was actually the
opening shots of the bitcoin civil war
and we haven't gotten past it
and then satoshi very suddenly
disappeared in late 2010 so the white
paper came out in 2008 late 2008 and
then he was gone by 2010 largely forced
out basically sick of bickering is the
way that i see it because it was
everybody saying satoshi you don't get
it and he's just saying like don't tell
me what i don't get about the thing that
i architected
and then at some point he just said you
know what i have so many other things to
do i'm going to pass the keys to
gavin andreessen he's the new lead
developer you guys are
okay and then he specifically said stop
referring to me as a shadowy figure and
stop treating bitcoin like crime money
that kind of thing like that's not what
he was interested in
and so then satoshi was gone and then
immediately his his repo was moved from
sourceforge and put onto github and a
bunch of new people were put in charge
and then all his stuff was burned down
the history of satoshi was whitewashed
and then it turned into hey here's this
big uh investment opportunity and by the
way we're we're creating this new voting
process with soft forks and and bitcoin
improvement uh proposal systems we're
gonna have uh this this group of
maintainers and so it turned from
governance by proof of work which is in
my opinion the most important thing
that's been invented in the last
probably 50 years
and then it turned into what is
essentially a social democracy which is
everything wrong with money today is the
fact that there are gatekeepers and
people can vote on it and some of the
votes happen behind closed doors and
then people are given this illusion of
voting with their quote unquote nodes
but they're not actually voting like
what they've been given to vote on is
already the the milk toast that has been
approved by the various levels
let's step back a little bit because i
want to keep this simple for the
audience to understand it so uh uh
simplify story craig wright says he's
the only person that's come out and said
he's satoshi nakamoto right i don't
think he's not there are other people
that have claimed they are else has
that's a credible name who else has
nobody credible everyone else is
following give me senator give me the
biggest name that came out that said
that phil wilson is probably the most
interesting guy phil wilson for the
record also says well yeah it was me and
craig and dave so even phil who i think
is kind of a sketchy character he's
another australian fellow
and and he tells the story it was me
craig wright and dave clyman
the interesting thing is that uh phil
wilson worked at some of the same
companies as contractors and stuff as
craig so one of the big reasons why i
really think that it's craig is a craig
has a background in statistics
finance economics theology he's he's
he's got
i don't even know half a dozen phds he's
got another 20 disastrous degrees
okay yeah i remember that so but craig
goes on bbc and he's going to put in the
keys and show the fact that he owns this
and then all of a sudden he's like oh
[ __ ] you know it's not working right and
it was a bit of a
you know controversial issue because if
you really say you are satoshi nakamoto
and you go on bbc and you kind of you
know flip-flop not able to show it he
lost a lot of credibility there's a
indeed and and this is why even to this
day he's he's among the most contentious
people in in the space they look at it
and say
if you couldn't prove it then you can't
prove it ever you're definitely not
satoshi nakamoto i think that's unfair
but the reason that i think it's unfair
is is specifically because i mean
there's a million reasons why that that
could be and i think that if he was a
scammer if this was all false he would
have disappeared at that point like who
wouldn't right if it's like okay
let me give the question back to you
okay
uh uh uh everybody in this room just a
question for everybody in this room okay
you ready
uh how many guys have
forgotten your chase or bank of america
or wells fargo password yeah absolutely
have you yeah okay have you have you
ever have you ever yes you have you have
you have as well you have as well okay
uh would we put a guy named craig wright
with 10 phds that's one of the smartest
guys if he really created uh uh bitcoin
you'd have to put him as one of the
smartest guys out there right sure okay
if he's one of the smartest guys out
there that produced a revolutionary
product by the way i want to believe it
sam i i enjoy talking to him i can't
wait to have him back on the podcast and
have a conversation with him if that is
the case the question that people bring
up is how does that guy forget it
because
the amount of money that he has is how
much is the money that he has 54 billion
or something no that's bigger than that
252 billion dollars yeah that was that's
not been core he would be the second
richest man in the world maybe the
richest man today because uh tesla took
a hit
so so if you're if that is like but
that's why some people think that he
forgot the the key as well so that they
can actually see go in and see exactly
how much he had how many hundreds of
thousands of coins he had in pre-mining
i mean if he was there if it wasn't
pre-mined it was it was public it was it
was said three months before like hey
mining starts sometime in the future
let's get set up like that that was the
point of coming with his partners pat i
mean like like the guy calvin air is the
interesting guy to me man like i mean
who who financed all this and if you
financed all this do you own bitcoin
like do you have an ownership state if
you financed everything are you the
owner of bitcoin have you financed
everything and if you know anything
about calvin air people that don't know
calvin air go follow his twitter he's a
very
interesting character he's an
interesting character he's a and he's a
serious disrupter he he's the guy that
brought internet to half of canada
uh he took the money that he made from
that and and created a software company
that disrupted the gambling industry
then he basically took over the online
gambling industry with bowdog and became
the number one online gambling mogul
period he also invented a number of
things that ended up competing with
paypal and things like that back in the
day which is why he got into the bitcoin
pretty incredible stuff also has a
predilection for females that even dan
bilzerian's like i don't know bro that's
a little young
you know
some of this stuff has come up in the
past and the people that have brought it
up have ended up having to uh
pay restitution and things to calvin so
it's
there are accusations and nothing's been
nothing's ever been proven charges have
never come out or any of that and he
happily shares the pictures across
twitter and very much understands the
legality issues that that would arise
should these things be uh
you know illegal so i i
so so okay so let's go back to this so
the florida trial so so far we talked
about craig wright fantastic he talked
about florida trial the
the trial of the century which you call
it so craig wright is here in miami
they're all talking what's going on wall
street journal does an article saying
bitcoin creator satoshi nakamoto could
be unmasked at florida trial right with
this going on it's almost a way of
saying you better come out and reveal
yourself right yeah has anybody else
stepped out outside a creek to say i am
the guy or no has there amid this trial
absolutely not like i mentioned phil
wilson there's been a couple of other uh
goofballs that have come out and told
told stories but none of them none of
them make any sense and and craig wright
is the only first of all craig didn't
out himself craig was doxed by wired and
gizmodo magazine in 2015.
uh at the same time the ato was raiding
his home and a local ato is the
australian irs
and the local media in australia was in
front of his house filming it so
somebody coordinated this basically
takedown of craig wright not realizing
he had left for the uk a few months
earlier and ultimately the reason craig
wright is a public figure at all is 100
not his doing so these magazines said
this man is satoshi nakamoto what can we
learn from him blah blah blah blah so i
think that's an important thing to
remember is that every other satoshi
candidate came out to say well i'm
satoshi and here's why and none of it
made any sense craig denied it for for
quite some time until he was able to get
some of his ducks in a row and then he
would say okay look i'm going to start
to i don't want to just tell everyone
publicly i'm going to bring in some
people privately so he brought in gavin
andreessen who's the guy who uh
satoshi left the keys with um the lead
developer of bitcoin and then uh he
brought in john mattonus who was the
head of the bitcoin foundation at the
time and a couple other people were
offered and as i understand it somewhere
between six and ten other people have
seen and he said look i wanna i wanna do
this right i wanna show you guys in
private i'm gonna do a a public key
private key signing prove that i control
satoshi nakamoto's assets and that that
is that is one aspect of proving that
i'm satoshi
the problem is that the second he did
that gavin andreessen had his keys
burned he was removed from bitcoin court
again amid the bitcoin civil war so
these people were like oh wow craig
wright is satoshi
boom gavin and jason you're out i'm so
confused man didn't you say satoshi
actually exists like as a human being a
hundred percent so other people know him
and have interacted with him correct but
there's this but it's on the internet
not in person but it's not in person i
mean is that right i know craig
personally yeah and
so i'm yes
my mind's being blown right is this like
a metaverse thing where craig is satoshi
online
craig so it's an alias it's a pseudonym
correct so there is no satoshi
as a human being it's a fake name
yeah exactly exactly exactly no that's
kind of like you write a book and you
don't want to use your name yeah like
gerard michaels i get it yeah i get it
but wait so there actually is no satoshi
nagamoto i mean there are probably
people on earth named no you didn't hear
about the story the guy that's
knocked on his door
and then he's like i'm telling you i'm
not i'm not the founder of bitcoin
so
i thought that there was still debate
whether this guy satoshi nakamoto
actually existed or if it was bs well
they're are you saying the name or the
human the human being yeah
i think people understand that it's a
human that created this his name wasn't
really satoshi nakamoto i didn't know
that that would have been great i didn't
even know that they could have been i
had no idea that that was that was
settled
science bro
trust the science man
so
anyways so then so then what happened is
gavin and driessen and john mattonus
both basically got burned kicked out of
the community you're not real bitcoiners
craig isn't real he's does this guy
gavin claim to have met
satoshi oh yeah he was under deposition
in miami court what did he say he said
you know what there were things that
were goofy about the whole situation but
at the end of the day i i believe that i
met satoshi nakamoto and who did he say
it was it was craig right so craig
wright is is kaiser sose
it's kaiser
satoshi yes kaiser satoshi nakamoto so
let me let me show you this let me show
you this let me show you this just just
in the last 30 days this is what's
happened i saw two articles so if you
want to pull this up uh one of them is
what hillary clinton said one of them is
what rand paul said i don't know if you
heard this i'm sure you did so if you
can pull this up a little bit higher a
little bit higher there you go with the
picture shown perfect bitcoin could
become world
reserve currency says senator rand paul
this is october 25th
a little over four weeks ago right this
is what he is saying
world reserve currency says rand paul
hillary clinton just comes out a week
ago or two weeks ago this is a week ago
she says
she fears bitcoin will undermine dollar
as world reserve currency which one is
more likely to happen or will both
happen
so i think they're both talking about
btc bitcoin because that's what people
assume i think it is incapable of being
the world reserve currency it doesn't
have the capacity to settle anything
near
what would be needed in in bandwidth
terms btc is heavily crippled it does
not work it really really only works for
what people are using it for today which
is an investment asset front run people
get other people to buy it you've become
more rich and that's great and that's
really everything that's going on there
it cannot do even with the layer 2 stuff
all of that stuff is is a lot of
vaporware and the stuff that works
really only works in in
bubbles
and so i i think frankly they're both
wrong but where they're right is that
the bitcoin protocol what satoshi
nakamoto actually invented is capable of
doing that it it should absolutely be a
both and it should be a frictionless
digital cache it should be a
tokenization layer it can do smart
contracts worldwide right now it in fact
is doing it uh but it's on bsv so what
bitcoin sv is and this is why craig
wright and all this stuff is tied
together is that bitcoin sv is bitcoin
as it was implemented by satoshi
nakamoto so there's no swim lanes in the
protocol
so whatever you want to try to do if you
want to try to push an entire operating
system in one transaction and then have
tokens interact with that operating
system all up in the stack you can do
that it's not going to stop you so
miners might stop you if you don't pay
in a fee the miner may not mine it and
put it on on chain i think the token's
pretty interesting because you could i
could anyway see a future where every
city has its own currency for sure it's
a token that's you know bitcoin based or
or some sort of blockchain absolutely
there be instead of paying cash to get
an mta card to ride the subway in new
york you'll have new york will have its
own coin it'll have its own token yes
and digital currency like pat was you
know we were talking about earlier there
there was land sold in in in uh in the
universe which is nuts to me man because
one of my favorite quotes from the
sopranos was when tony soprano you know
tries to give fatherly advice to aj it's
like buy land god ain't making no more
of it god's making more land now it's
digital land that's crazy no it's true
so i mean you know the go go west young
young sun west expansion and and this is
40 meter acres and a mule and this is
and this is why so
this is why
i i'm such an advocate for the bitcoin
protocol which again in my belief really
only exists in bitcoin sv
it's the only one that can do those
things so right now like and just for
clarification bitcoin sv is different
than btc correct so they both break that
down they're both based on the bitcoin
protocol in a very basic sense so
it's it's kind of like the the judaism
christianity lds
islam and all these things like there's
forks right but they fundamentally are
abrahamic they're fundamentally
abrahamic religions right so this is
this is all these bitcoin variants are
fundamentally satoshi ish
implementations of bitcoin including
things like litecoin or purecoin or dash
all these things are still like 95 the
same thing at the very base level but
the way they're implemented has has a
bunch of different variables and so btc
is bitcoin but implemented with a bunch
of the stack turned off so the op codes
the stuff that would allow smart
contracts a lot of it just turned off
because like ah that stuff's kind of a
security issue we don't want to play
with that also we don't want more than
six megabytes per hour to go across the
whole network or else people in the
third world won't be able to operate
nodes and we want everyone to be able to
have an end point on the network isn't
this what ripple wanted to do but they
just were dumb enough to incorporate in
the united states or yeah i mean
ripple's the same thing ripple is is
also very similar to bitcoin in most
ways that matter so almost every
blockchain is is basically just a
derivation of the same idea so what
bitcoin sv is is okay we're going to
implement bitcoin but we're not going to
have any hard limits on things so
whatever you want to try to do whatever
economic actors want to push on the
economy and see if they can create a
market create an economy with a new idea
you can do it on bsv today like ethereum
you can't do it the nfts on ethereum
aren't even actually on ethereum you own
a string of numbers you don't own the
artwork in fact people are getting
censored off of ethereum right now for
their political cartoons like if you put
a political cartoon that is unsavory in
some way you can just eliminate the art
because the art is sitting on open seas
server or it's sitting on aws or it's
sitting maybe on ipfs but that art
disappears and you only own the hash
bitcoin sv right now there are like 3d
objects as nfts
made in i mean you can grab them you can
play with them but they're on chain
they're in the blockchain they can't be
deleted and that's the only blockchain
that does it everybody else is selling
you a string of digits and they're
hosting your file on their servers and
whenever they feel like you know what
i'm done with this they shut the server
off and you lost the piece of art you
think you own let me let me ask you do
you own any bitcoin or ethereum
i i own a little bit of a lot of things
but a lot of it is is old school like
i've been in the space for nine years
now so some of it is i probably have
stuff that i don't even know exists at
this point but not to answer with joe
biden's guy right now no no what do you
mean that you know doesn't exist does
that mean um so i mean just in testing
like if we're going back to 2015 so i
actually used to be an ethereum miner i
was mining monero in
2016 and 17 like i've i've gotten myself
into a lot of things to like what is the
most recent coin you invested in what
you bought recent um
bsv i'm heavy in the bsv space got it so
when you so let's talk about the mining
the difference between ethereum mining
and bitcoin you'll see uh one of the
arguments will come up to mine one
bitcoin cost you know you hear somebody
the 48 thousand dollars 42 000 et cetera
et cetera explain to the average person
what it means that it costs 42 48 000 to
mine a bitcoin or mining ethereum which
is what you used to do yep um so what
you're doing when you're mining is
you're actually you're trying to brute
force a number so the the network says
find this number and here's a bunch of
math problems to get you there and then
what you do is what's called a brute
force so you get a bunch of computers to
test is it this number is it that number
is it this number is it that number but
they're doing it at an incredible speed
and just absolutely bonkers speed in
fact this is the most uh progress in
computer science and moore's law and all
this stuff has been toward breaking
hashes specifically for hashing on on
blockchain assets so what you're doing
is you're hunting for
one number and in bitcoin that is a
sha-256 number and on ethereum right now
it's it's eth hash which is a i'm not
going to get into the the math and
science of it because nobody cares but
um
in ethereum you use gpus so it is like
the graphics cards that that people want
on their gaming computer this is why
gamers hate crypto people because they
can't get the gpus to make their games
cool because they just keep getting
bought up by by ethereum miners
primarily i hate the crypto people they
do
and so what you're doing there is you
can run a gpu farm which is quieter it's
a lot less energy efficient but it's
it's the best way to mine ethereum today
and and so a lot of people gpu mine and
that's what they do on shot 256 it's
specifically asic mining which is
application specific integrated circuit
meaning it is a computer that is
designed to do absolutely nothing but
look for bitcoin hashes
and so it's very very heavily
specialized whereas ethereum miners when
they're you know if you decide you know
what i don't want to be an ethereum
miner anymore you can put those gpus on
ebay and sell them to the gamers again
and the gamers oh there's been a drop we
get to do this so but ultimately what
you're doing as a miner
you're looking for a hash and that's
really all you're doing what's a hash
a hash is
it's a string of numbers that represents
some other thing so i can make uh let's
say i write the number
my birthday and then i run it through an
algorithm it will spit out a hash and
the algorithm can always connect that
hash to my birthday if that's what i
wanted to do so it's a proof of the
existence of the first thing
but hashes mean it can be something as
simple as a very simple like like my
birthday written out or it can be a
whole novel like i can make it moby dick
i can make it the entire library of
congress and i can hash it and the hash
will be the same size regardless of the
input correct it is digital dna it's a
fingerprint that points to the proof of
existence of another thing
but in a way that is standardized and
easily attestable
so that's what they're looking for
they're looking so why does it cost so
much money though
because it's competitive so specifically
it's if i can do it better than you
then then i will because i'll make that
money but if but if gerard figures out a
new way to do it
maybe he's got better uh
whatever but better computer science
background or he can pay somebody to
build a better chip then all of a sudden
he's more rig's more energy he's more
competitive than us then i need to
figure out oh shoot what do i do like do
i go to the third world and and try to
find an old diesel plant and make it
that my power is cheaper or whatever so
it's this competitive nature it is free
market economics 100 percent at play
that makes it that i'm going to compete
with you but then you're going to
compete better but yeah why is the
argument about it
the reason why bitcoin will never end up
being the currency is because it costs
so much money and it's it requires so
much energy and power right why do why
does that constantly come up um because
most people are communists and they
don't realize it so people that talk
about costs without talking about roi
are
dim period it's roi
[Laughter]
you say anything bad about communism
this guy's trying to make out with you
on camera he took off you're on your
head i feel i believe you're on such a
level kirk
this guy's slightly uh poking out right
now
but it's true though so the cost the the
cost conversation is fine but but people
that talk about costs without roi
aren't having a real conversation these
are people that that should go get a
minimum wage job and stay in their lane
so
but but if you're creating you're saying
you're saying experts don't say that
you're saying uh like for example can
you google
uh uh tyler do me a favor google
what it call how much energy does mining
a bitcoin uh uh take
so apparently it's more energy there you
go google it but it's the time tesla
everything combined no the
the only reason i'm at okay stay right
there let me just read that real quick
uh uh if you want to uh uh
go back go back real quick uh okay so
business insider is not a communist yet
i mean i know we're going after business
insider's got a bad reputation with
whatever's going on but
bitcoin mining consumes around 91
terawatt hours of electricity annually
okay bitcoin mining
that's more annual electricity
used than of all of finland which is a
country of five and a half million
people that's almost half a percent of
all of the electricity consumption
worldwide and a 10 times jump from just
five years ago so this isn't a
you know
reddit crazy you know
uh a guy that's saying this so go back
go go into the article let's read a
little bit more
go all the way to the top let me just
read this out bitcoin minus consumes uh
then globally and seven times google's
total usage new report says and google
is the number one search engine go a
little lower
uh go a little over half a percent uh
consumption according to new york times
that's roughly seven times on google
bitcoin's negative environmental impact
is expected to become a bigger issue as
cryptocurrency gains more popularity
okay by the way i see the fact
if new york times is saying this and
they're linking it to environmental
impact you already know where this is
going next
see more so go a little lower go a
little lower see what else they're
saying about this it is difficult to
measure exactly how much energy would
come in and consumes but a new analyst
by the new york times shared some
staggering info input okay and that's
the stuff that we just read right now so
it's not um
you know it's not just
one person saying it or two people
saying that sure i'm really trying to
find out for myself
if we're going in a direction right now
where
uh
we keep printing money okay which has
been the strategy for the last 24 months
okay and the printing of money is not
left and right bush started it back in
the days with you know we we can talk
about quantitative easing that started
with
uh who's the first greenspan was it
greens
yes so hey quantitative easing is
actually a good thing you know we go by
give money to the banks and they buy
shitty business that's out of business
but you're putting money in there and
hopefully the money is going to go to
the middle income and then eventually
realize the more they're doing that
inflation next thing you know we got 6.2
percent we can't wait to see what the
numbers are going to be next so for me i
i i would like to see a
potential different currency that holds
everybody accountable that you cannot
manipulate specifically the government
cannot so it would be kind of cool to
have a different currency some said hey
we're going to go to gold standard peter
schiff gold standard nothing's happened
with gold the last 18 months i've owned
gold nothing's happened with gold in the
last 18 months right so
if there is a possibility of us going on
something that publicly you can count
and they can't print that'd be a
beautiful thing but the fact that it
takes that much energy
in today's climate don't you see that as
an issue i don't and in fact um
if you look at bitcoin mining versus
what is going on in the rest of the
world like you're ignoring like yes
google and google is a big player but
they're not the only player if you look
at the entire global economy and what
they are doing in order to bootstrap
whatever we call the global financial
system so all these things all these
players they're using exponentially more
energy than than bitcoin now here's my
problem again with with bitcoin btc is
that what are we doing with all that
energy on btc what we're essentially
doing is securing a bunch of coins that
are sitting on people's
paper wallets or ledger nanos or
whatever you know they're sitting there
they're not doing it they're not
creating anything with that money and
this is a problem for me too this is why
i actually argue that the btc community
has become
bourgeoisie whatever they're they're
very um they've got a communist
pension to their to their behavior
they're not building things with bitcoin
they're not using bitcoin as a tool to
disrupt the actual economy and so it
does become a problem then it does
become wasteful if this is just securing
what's in my wallet that's that is a
problem and it's it's not a problem for
me to to go out and physically change
for someone else it's incumbent upon me
to build business use cases that that
supersede that so imagine if what i was
doing with bitcoin was replacing twitter
for example twitter's a giant nightmare
of a company they're a terrible company
but everybody uses them because
everybody's there but they're they're
also very wasteful think about how much
server space is actually exist just to
keep twitter online now if we were to
move over to bitcoin and bsv for example
has the the twitch network which you
have an account as i recall i do yeah i
do i spoke to the founder of it him and
i went back and forth
uh uh
i had different interests with them but
yeah yeah i do have an account with them
and so so what they've done is they are
they are putting everything on chain in
the stack it's it's up in bitcoin it
runs in bitcoin it's not using other
infrastructure so we can ignore we can
eliminate amazon web services and
microsoft azure and all these other
things that are also consuming a lot of
energy but it also has the added benefit
of extreme censorship resistance people
can have political opinions that are
maybe unsavory but can't be deleted just
because jack dorsey or this new goon ceo
can uh you know well i don't i don't
like the sound of that and it's it's all
on chain it's a it's
secured by proof of work and again this
proof of work this brute forcing of
ideas so imagine the hash we talked
about brute forcing hashes imagine brute
forcing every idea and making every node
around the the world use that power use
that energy to to to take conflicting
ideas
speak to speak to the audience as if
they're a fifth grader right now because
you went to la la i know i i so come
back and simplify for us let me go back
to the question here's a question
if it requires this much energy that
people say it requires you want to use
the example of twitter it's seven times
google which means twitter's probably
freaking fantastic nothing it's nothing
compared to google right i mean you
can't even compare the two it's probably
700 times uh twitter if not more right
so that comparison argument somebody
might find a leak and poke it and say i
don't know what by what you're saying
here all i'm going back to is remember i
would love to see an alternative to fiat
currency i think most people would love
that where the government cannot just
say let's go mine 50 million more
bitcoins you can't [ __ ] like that
right so we don't have to worry about
all the other stuff
why is this constant conversation about
how much energy it requires to mine a
bitcoin
because people aren't focused on what
you can create with that cost people are
just looking at the cost and saying that
is a that is awful consumption and if
you just look at the consumption i agree
yeah and and i agree to the point that
people aren't creating disruptive things
with their blockchain let me let me
restate the question i'll ask the
question a different way i'll ask the
question a different way so uh uh for
example okay
uh you know we'll talk about mafia
states of america we'll give an update
before the whole thing ends because
people need to know what's going on with
that but hypothetically okay
um how many total hours have we put into
mafia states of america total everybody
team
you know think about where we were at
shooting
40 people they're editors can we say
i don't know total everybody 10 000
hours is that a fair number
maybe more okay let's just say 10 000
hours ago let's just say 10 000 hours
now
uh i
the the funder is gonna sit there and
say why is this costing so much money
it's taking so many hours it's freaking
ridiculous i don't have manpower to get
these guys to edit other projects i have
nine editors working on this one project
gerard this is freaking ridiculous right
however however
if
when we're done qc and all of it this
week which is going to release december
3rd we are done
putting any time into it because now
it's up there then i'm good meaning if
that energy is required to mine a
bitcoin it's just the energy required
until you mine it then it's good to go
it doesn't require any more energy we're
fine no but is it a constant energy
required to sustain it because that's a
concern so the other thing that occurs
is that uh you are
a transaction processor as well so the
same people that are mining the bitcoins
are also processing the transactions so
as transactions occur that that's also
part of the consumption on btc it's
almost none comparatively sure but bsv
for example has more transaction uh
more of what's going on on that network
is transactions than it is mining so
and and this is this is why i say like
look if if we're building a world that
is disruptive that is more efficient
it's more
fair in a way that is verifiable not
arbitrarily fair but like look at the
math look kurt to me that's a complete
red herring man i mean you know if
you're using five percent of the world's
energy that's governmental that's that's
not people in their in their backyard on
their computers that means that world
governments are using a lot of their
energy grid to be able to do that right
el salvador specifically one of these
countries that's moving to it as their
primary currency
the other thing about that is is that
our energy production is only just
beginning remember a hundred years ago
you know the world war one started and
calvary was still involved like world
war one began and they were still i
believe it was poland was going up
against tanks in actual with horses yeah
so i mean we basically just came out of
the middle ages guys 100 100 years from
now our energy capacity is going to be
something that we can't even really
begin to understand so so i think i
think the other thing to know about
power right now is that that there is
more power generated than is used so
until we actually get to the point where
we're putting real strain on the grid i
think it's an irrelevant concept haven't
even captured a power of the sun man
but even right now
as inefficient as our power generation
is we're generating too much power even
with bitcoin and even with all the other
inefficiencies that are perceived we're
creating more energy than is used my big
issue with like to me that that's an
obvious you know to me again everybody's
a communist right but i mean to me that
that's just an obvious hit piece so what
does concern me is a little bit of the
decentralization like who can take over
bitcoin pat talked about a fiat currency
what p for people that don't know
basically it means that that the united
states dollar isn't backed by anything
there's nothing back there's no gold
standard you can't tie it to anything
there's nothing your paper dollar in
your pocket is based on nothing more
than faith it's as real as satoshi all
right it's
it really is it's as real so you know
the the but bitcoin doesn't have
aircraft carriers so there's that aspect
of it you know so you know our fed
reserve
for as bad as it is and i think it the
fed reserve and the wbo are two of the
most evil organizations on earth i
really honestly believe that with every
fiber in my being
and they sell for people that don't know
the federal reserve isn't even a
government agency it's a private bank
that sells money to the united states we
buy our money folks the money then your
pocket is worth less the second you get
it than the second it was printed we buy
our money from a private bank so
moving away from this like pat said i
think is is absolutely crucial to every
american citizens also why they'll never
let us do it number one number two
what is to stop bitcoin from from
becoming a world back currency let's say
and then somebody like calvin air being
like oh yeah by the way i own this and
now you guys have to pay this price or
this or that like what what's to stop
that from happening well i think first
of all the right question the way that
it's distributed first of all like
there's a reason why it wasn't
distributed by you know craig wright
patent this and that copyright this and
that it's it's cop it's actually
copywritten to satoshi nakamoto and it's
got an open source mit license so it's
basically look modify it if you want do
what you want to it but if you make a
modification you need to change the name
so
if it's bitcoin it's bitcoin run bitcoin
and then the way that it's distributed
the way that it's processed and
everything is 100 competitive again it
is a pure free market function and this
is why it really matters this is why i
don't like with btc that the the bip
process and this what has really become
democratic socialism in the way that
that changes are made and changes are
implemented in btc i think it's a major
problem bitcoin is supposed to be
governed 100 by proof-of-work and if
everybody agrees that look you need to
compete to create the most value but
even there before you move on from that
kurt who governs it
like how is it governable who's holding
each other accountable like what is the
process of that accountability we can
say it's proof of work but you know also
if there's no fines or penalties like
but there is that's the point of proof
of work if you do something that is
unsavory to the other nodes in the
network if your proof of work appears to
be malicious they can just simply say
you know what we're done with you we're
not going that direction the proof of
work will orphan your ideas off of the
network that's the beauty of it is that
if you aren't creating value the second
you have decided maybe i'm going to be a
malicious king you will cease to be the
king period we've seen it hundreds of
times in bitcoin every time there used
to be the the bit main oh bit main is
going to take over and they're this this
big conglomerate and ultimately people
are like you know what we don't like bit
main we're just basically going to do
things that make them go away and
they've they've had to completely change
they've reorganized
you can obviously see the next logical
step in that is okay now china just
comes in overwhelms the system and says
everything that that's not pro us we can
orphan the same way but but they really
can't because again it's it's based on
its principle and proof of work so if
they come in
with with something that again is
malicious to the network the network
itself is anti-fragile in that it can
say we're basically going to go a
different direction i understand what
that means the network is it ai the
network
a person is corruptable if in a perfect
free market system i believe that in a
perfect free market system we will still
have malicious actors we'll still have
serial killers we'll have these things
but if we are all able to compete 100 to
be
anything we can be if we can cooperate
better whoever cooperates best will win
and they should win but the way that
they win is by creating the most value
for the rest of everyone else so i would
actually hope that communist china says
okay we need to mine we need to
participate in this economic disruption
by being a node on the network because
it will create incentives that make them
better people too
that's that's my desire i want
governments to stop having cold wars and
hot wars with each other i want them to
have to mine about it they need to brute
force their ideas that's what mining is
it is brute forcing to find the best
path forward and i would rather have
these things brute forced rather than
we're invading each other's countries or
whatever else okay adam's got a question
i i got to follow people i uh yeah i i
feel like we're learning a lot but i
also think that there's some people that
are because i'm one of them that's like
way over my head right now here bro
straight
so let's bring this down to just regular
people out there most people are most
people i say this all the time i i
gravitate towards personal finance
that's what i care about make your money
save that money invest that money yada
yada yep um
talk to the regular people out there the
nine to fivers they're making 50 grand a
year 100 grand a year whatever is going
on they're getting their paycheck you
know they're putting their money in
their 401k they're renting they have a
mortgage they've got kids yada yada yada
freakin yada and then you're like bitty
bop and beating [ __ ] and bit it out and
betty boop
blockchain it's like pump the brakes for
a second bro sure how does this affect
the regular person the regular person
can't afford bitcoin maybe they're
buying some dogecoin and praying maybe
they're buying some fractionalized
shares of bitcoin maybe they're like
look bro i see what's going on nft
like you know you're familiar with like
jump to shark yeah i had a buddy out
there that all he does is smoke blunts
every single day hit me up he's like bro
what's up with these nfts i was like
that's it i'm out
okay
my question to you is bring this back to
the normal person why should they even
give a [ __ ] about what you're saying i
don't mean that disrespectfully but
they're just like look bro
i just want to make my money i want to
save some money i want to live my life
you're talking about nodes and nerds and
this and that
just break this down for the regular
person out there
what should they be aware of
what should they be most most concerned
about and just break that down
the first thing is that dollars are a
tool for oppression it's it's bait
it's it's sell your time for this you
can't get the time back but you will get
these dollars
and people do that people work the nine
to five they're commuting an hour each
way and and having their kids and doing
essentially everybody yeah
but those dollars are losing value as
they're sitting in your bank account
mm-hmm inflation's killing our ability
to purchase things you know now a year
ago inflation's not a thing now
inflation might be good and here's why
you know so this is something that we
are we're just total gaslighting by the
way what they're doing they're saying
inflation is good i mean they're just
trying to get middle america to say okay
it's not a big deal right yeah i mean
you've been talking about inflation for
six months man i mean you called it when
janet yeah leland was like it's only one
percent you're like rolling your eyes
it's a mess four years it's a major six
point two percent it's a major usually
two to three percent so it's double what
it usually is it's to make us rely on
them
what what bitcoin does fundamentally is
it gives us tools that allows me to do
business with someone in south carolina
as easily as i can do business with
someone in south korea
and it makes it that i can bootstrap a
business i can be a fintech startup with
a trivial amount of capital as opposed
to
all right i need to write a thing i need
to go to some silicon valley venture
capital and like there's a whole this
whole process that's not the regular
person out there remember we're talking
to regular people here right silicon
valley
but that's what i'm saying is
that that's the silo that's the silo
that a regular person can't ever broach
they can't get there okay but with
bitcoin
excuse me with bitcoin you have the
ability to create things of value
in an hour's time on your own computer
and sell these things for real value you
can do business on the bitcoin network
much the same way that that the internet
allowed people to maybe create a an ebay
business on the side 15 years ago right
like oh wow i've got extra income
because i figured out that i can go buy
you know designer shoes at the resale
shop and then sell them for 10x what i
bought them for right that was a
revolutionary little thing that the
internet created for people but bitcoin
is that much better because you can do
it with digital assets you can tokenize
your own
your own home your own life future is on
your own ability to earn things like
that it gives financial instruments that
have been
kept away from people
forever and it allows them to be in the
hands of people to
do micro lending let's say maybe you've
got 50 grand that you've saved up
because you've you know kept the bank
account for
30 years working at your job
well that 50 grand how can you make that
50 grand work for you you can leave it
uh that ira or whatever the thing is
i probably got allergies here
but with bitcoin he's got cats
it allows you to do
uh micro this defy thing like it allows
people to give i'm gonna give a micro
loan i'm gonna choose the interest rate
i'm gonna i'm gonna allow people to drop
some tissue please
appreciate it so i'm i'm i'm going to be
a lender in my neighborhood now and the
on-chain attestation of my identity and
my reputation makes it that people can
trust me we can have a smart contract
secure it and do the escrow and take
away all of the nonsense the stuff that
people don't want to know and hear and
say look you can earn six percent on
your dollar now by lending two people
and i literally think that gerard what i
was telling you yeah you want to tell us
what you do no okay
because it's illegal have some tissues
thank you no and uh you get very
emotional
is this this way
let me tell you let me let me let me
let me he was fine for the communist
let me read an article here about
because uh so so kurt you know the
comments right now are on fire about dsv
right
yeah so they love bsv apparently i mean
i'm being sarcastic so can you pull up
this article about what vitali had to
say uh uh
so uh uh yahoo article this is two years
old though this is not a new article
it's two years old ethereum's vitalik
materian slams bitcoin sv obviously a
complete scam if he can go up a little
bit ethereum vitalik maintained his
hardline stance on bitcoin
sv in a recent interview calling craig
craig writes cryptocurrency complete
scam speaking with you to our consumer
little room for interpretation regarding
his thoughts on bsp the theorem
co-founder also gave his thoughts on
decentralized exchanges and the
warringly centralized accumulation of
power by uh uh binance go a little lower
obviously bsv is a complete scan but the
the the listing from binance that was
interesting there's arguments in favor
of it but then there's also an argument
that this is a centralized exchange
that's wielding a lot of power
what do you have to say about his
thoughts against bsv
i mean we're
we bsv makes ethereum completely
obsolete so i mentioned ethereum is good
for 15 tsv makes the ethereum completely
absolutely ethereum is good for 15
transactions per second globally and it
does smart contracts that cost sometimes
800 a transaction just to make a wallet
or just to do all these different things
which would obviously concern our friend
vitalik there is there was no scaling
ceiling on bsv but zero in fairness
ethereum was never intended to be a
transactable currency or an investment
it's you know what there are there if
you go look at vitalik buterin quotes
from 2017 he was the one talking about
that it's a travesty that btc fees are
over five dollars or whatever he's oh no
that could never be disruptive and now
you know literally eight hundred dollars
to make an ethereum wallet if you're
trying to open a defy contract and it's
it's madness but on bsv you can do about
a hundred thousand transactions per
second today
full smart contracts everything that
ethereum can do can be done for an
infinitesimal fraction of the cost and
at exponentially higher speed than
ethereum and that's why bsv is a scam in
his opinion people don't want to hear it
the reason it's been delisted from
binance and from all these other places
is because the entire crypto economy all
10 000 of these blockchains some days
bsv has more transactions on just bsv
than the entire rest of the blockchain
economy combined nobody talks about it
and it's because it's their ponzi scheme
they're making money by trading tokens
and by accruing this liquidity what bsv
does is not about crypto trading that's
not the thing here what it is is it is
disrupting the entire global economy we
don't want to replace the blockchain
economy we want to replace the internet
period do you think those blockchains
are going to consolidate at some point
they have to they don't work like they
literally need to bring whatever value
is on those blockchains needs to come to
bsv because the other blockchains don't
work they can't scale people don't get
it l2 all this layer two nonsense four
years ago ethereum's oh plasma is going
to fix everything plasma never came out
it can't work elon moyes just came in so
he's in he's in the chat he's watching
the uh no no i'm being serious
he's a twitch guy
so he came in he says bitcoin does the
work of a hundred thousand bankers per
second what does he mean by that
that it's everything bitcoin is bitcoin
isn't is a global notary it is a it is a
global group of bankers it is a global
uh data attestation service it is the
internet that's the thing everything you
can do if you want it's the deed you buy
a car with bitcoin and it is your deed
the coin is everything every single
piece of ownership identity and
transaction
period can can happen on bsv if if we
were to move the entire global economy
to a blockchain today it would have to
be bsv it could not be done on another
blockchain period
so
chamath says 200 000 by the end of next
year what do you think
i think he's a madman i think i think
he's
here's the thing it could be if it if it
does it'll be because it's the it's the
inflation meme it's the problem
sure but he's been wrong before
yeah so back uh i don't think it'll be
that will primarily
if
if if that's the case
if it's the case it'll be primarily an
indicator for how bad the economy has
gotten it will not be because of value
that was created
so it's a hedge against it's a hedge
against hyperinflation it is the only
thing that people are using it for
that's it are you familiar with this
bitcoin rainbow
no i don't think so you're not what is
it
okay i mean maybe maybe not by a
different name what are we talking about
it's called the bitcoin rainbow i don't
know only you would know something like
let's hear it is it a gay pride thing no
i'm not saying that it's just like
bitcoin rainbow price you got a hundred
questions to ask you're asking my
bitcoin because this is essentially the
predictor of what's going to happen yes
okay so what's it telling us yeah yeah
you've never seen this i have seen this
okay okay all of a sudden i'm teaching
you something
bitcoin
this is exactly like it's sort of like
the
teacher's manual this is insane tell me
why we shouldn't laugh at whoever made
this seriously like look at this what is
this i don't know but apparently it
works
no what it is is you overlay it on
something that exists like this didn't
exist 10 years ago somebody put this
together a couple years ago at the very
it was that yeah
any rational person should look at this
and laugh like what is it even telling
us
well i think we can all agree that the
word rational is a very loose
terminology these days with the
metaverse and the nfts and the bitcoins
and the video bombs none of this is
rational bro that indicates that we are
in a bubble that will crash okay let's
talk about that what's this bubble you
hear the bitcoin bubble the crypto
bubble the dogecoin bubble what's the
bubble it's the same reason people don't
work at the at the burger stand anymore
either it's the same reason there's
supply shortages everywhere it's the
same reason we can't get port workers to
to unload
however a half a million ships or
whatever that are off the coast of
california it's because the entire
economy is broken the entire economy is
slowing down it is fundamentally
changing in ways that are not good okay
it's because people are being paid to be
lazy right and it's the exact same thing
they're doing with cryptocurrency they
look at it and they're like oh well i
mean you should buy this thing you may
never have to work again like buy shiba
inu coin and okay here it is man and
it's like okay what does shiba do who is
what what economic utility is being
unlocked by shiba inu coin what do any
of these coins do for that matter
nothing the answer is nothing and that's
the problem are you basically predicting
a crypto crash
yes it's all nonsense
okay
well i mean you're the bitcoin guy so
like the fact that you're saying that
the fact that you're saying that crypto
is all nonsense
alarm bells should be going off right
now
he so so
you have to know that if pomp was
sitting here right now we would have to
separate them because they have complete
opposite you know because pomp is a
bitcoin loyalist right
and and he may be one of the best uh
explainers of bitcoin out there when i
listen to palm i say yeah i walk away
saying okay cool you know so his
position is a different position than a
pomp then a
there's a lot of again go back to the
religion civil war can you put up this
question somebody just asked i'm curious
to know what your thoughts are on this
and we're going to change the subject
and go into jack dorsey and a few other
guys and maybe we'll talk about uh some
more about this bitcoin rainbow but go
go to what i just sent you uh uh i know
if you see it or not try to try to get
it over just give me a second trying to
get it okay all right so anyways i'll
read it to you while he's trying to
figure this out tyler
so uh john pitts at equity diamonds i
don't know if you know who he is or not
i do okay you know who he is he asks
number one question how would bdo
an audit firm which relies on its
integrity minutes
which are independently produced csv has
no control
not be a smoking gun that csv equals sn
can you unpack that question for us and
then answer that then i got to follow up
second question for you this is strictly
for the bitcoin community how would you
respond to that so i've been in court
can you unpack this question by the way
this is from the the and right trial i
have been at every single day every
single minute of this trial taking notes
and doing a live stream every evening
for it so uh there might not be there's
one other guy who who is probably
equally expertise on this and it's my
buddy pat
but um there was a piece of evidence
admitted
my buddy pat thompson but that's my
buddy
craig wright gave a piece of evidence
that was minutes on bdo letterhead from
2007 this is about a year before the
bitcoin white paper came out and it was
explaining
uh time chain p2p cash system and and
and giving a timeline of when he wants
to do these things and whether or not
bdo
wants to invest in this idea and make it
a bdo product bitcoin as a commercial
essentially triple entry accounting
system which would be great for bdo in
theory okay but they didn't understand
the opportunity so
basically what it is is this is proof of
about a year before bitcoin released of
craig wright showing bdo what is
essentially bitcoin and explaining all
right we'll release the white paper in
q3 of 2008 we'll get the software done
and tested you know during this timeline
we'll try to release by early 2009
and uh and there's a guy named alan
granger who's some kind of executive at
bdo in australia basically signing off
on it and it was going to be
greenlighted except the economy
collapsed and ultimately uh research and
development projects and stuff ended up
getting booted in fact craig also got
let go from the bdo uh just a few months
later not for malfeasance but simply
because hey we're letting a bunch of
people go because of the economy so this
is why bitcoin became satoshi nakamoto
project instead of
bitcoin trademark a bdo product
so
um i i think it's a
very compelling piece of evidence i
think it's a piece of evidence that
people were not expecting
and people want to write it off and
they're like oh it's a handwritten note
it could have come from any time
anywhere but it's well but it's on bdo
letterhead and
and time stamped and all these things so
i think it's a major smoking gun a major
bombshell and another piece of evidence
of craig wright for which
i saw about a thousand pieces of
evidence that um that basically couldn't
point to anything else so to answer your
question from probably an hour ago why
craig writes satoshi nakamoto if craig
wright is not satoshi nakamoto he's been
pretending to be since about two years
before bitcoin existed
and doing almost nothing else with his
time it just wouldn't make any he
wouldn't have time to do anything else
and so how'd you answer the second
question if bit cash bitcoin email from
2008 is indeed a fraud as csv csv equals
craig wright right as csv
csw
how does klyman have a case at all i i
personally don't think climate has a
case at all it doesn't make sense to me
the the whole thing is is predicated on
craig wright being a bad man and trying
to get money for the estate the way that
i see it i think it's a giant moment
anyone going to jail
no absolutely no it's a civil symbol
and also in a civil case though you
don't need all 12 jurors to agree it's
only it's you only need a majority and
fyi for the audience
let's listen to this a lot of people are
asking about having john e deaton on
just so you know he's the founder of
crypto law dot us and uh he's a uh
lawyer
known in the crypto community we are
having conversations about having him on
the podcast and we'll talk about what's
going on with the case so i know people
are asking about it him and i have
started communicating in the last week
or so we'll let you know when that does
take place okay having said that let's
get right into a couple topics that we
got here uh i'll give you a few names in
your world and you just give me one word
or any thoughts you have on these names
curious to know what your thoughts are
going to be so number one uh pompliano
anthony
never never saw an opportunity that he
didn't want to ride
okay brian armstrong
uh similar yeah he's uh brian armstrong
i i think is a guy who was bitcoin only
until the moment it became inconvenient
and then he just did what the money told
them by the way for people that don't
know it's coinbase right ceo and founder
of coinbase yeah vitalik buterin
uh
an interesting character i i think he's
also very much in it for the money he he
knows his stuff doesn't scale he's even
admitted his stuff doesn't scale on
stage and um
he's here for the money he's here to
make money okay i'm gonna have a hard
time i'm gonna butcher this name juchika
chow
a chicken i don't even know okay i will
go to the next one jack dorsey uh
jack dorsey is a communist who thinks
he's a libertarian
okay i mean try to not hold back a
little bit
terry duffy
terry duffy i don't know terry jamie
dimon
uh
[Music]
from jp morgan yeah um
i don't know he's a bank ceo what is
there to say about
charlie lee
uh total scammer if if you look into
charlie lee charlie lee is an insider
manipulator to the core period
you just pissed off another group of
people that are not going to be happy
with you naval ravikant
i
i like his tweets i think he used to be
a lot better a few years ago i think i
think he's running out of axioms i'll
ask you craig wright you've already said
stuff about craig right but craig wright
uh a gigantic pain in the ass and also
satoshi nakamoto okay elizabeth rosiello
our don't know barry silbert
uh barry silbert is
one of the heads of the beast that is
there to completely strangle out
um what bitcoin was designed to do and
he's doing it all for money and if you
look at his board of directors it's all
people from the world bank and the
clinton foundation and a bunch of stuff
pretending to be disruptive cool you
know bitcoin people and they're not
they're a bunch of nasty nasty
banker
okay elizabeth stark lightning labs
um
she's a fall person
okay brad garland cows
uh
brad's a brilliant ceo and i think he's
also a
piece of trash but i think i think he
does a great
i think so it's a brilliant piece of
trash i like that can we make sure we
escort this guy
he cannot kevin
so here's the thing xrp is is 100 the
only thing that ripple labs does they
would not have revenue if it wasn't for
pumping xrp so he's a brilliant ceo and
that he's figured out ways to make you
know people in that company some of the
richest 1.3 billion in the world so
that's what i mean he's brilliant ceo
but his company actually does nothing
but put out press releases about hey
we're doing this thing with western
union we're good none of it actually
exists he also you gotta give him credit
he went he tried to he was the very
first guy that went head to head with
the us dollar he was like yeah let's do
it he's
he's a mixed bag you remember brad but
he is he is not he is not a disrupter he
is he is there to make money for ripple
period so when people and and people
know this at the miami miami party i'll
tell you about after mark cuban
uh
i don't like mark cuban at all i i i
used to until
i i don't he's just another opportunist
like would i accept money from him
with a lot of strings attached maybe but
billy
paula rose in prison for human
trafficking and gun smuggling uh is a
gigantic piece of human trash i hope he
gets the chair at some point
kevin anderson
gavin and driessen yeah uh
gavin is
way too nice to have been involved in
bitcoin and let himself be manipulated
by way too many people but i think he's
a good man he how finney i haven't met
him unfortunately hal finney uh
brilliant programmer uh very cool guy an
actual libertarian by the way uh i like
hal finney
uh wrong about bitcoin and ultimately uh
not not satoshi a lot of people think
half any satoshi i don't think because
he died uh what five years ago 2013.
maybe
that's sort of like the kaiser soze
approach and he had uh als i want to say
and
also actually a libertarian but i think
he's 100 wrong about bitcoin i think
he's been wrong about cryptocurrency for
a very long time actually he created a
precursor to bitcoin that failed because
it didn't make any sense and he keeps
trying to turn bitcoin into that thing
because that will vindicate him i think
he's trying to get back the thing that
he lost 20 years ago
dave kleinman
uh dave so dave kliman died in 2013 also
nobody in the space ever really met him
is from
being in this case and hearing all of
his stories dave kleinman seems like he
was probably one of the nicest people to
have had in your life
and he died tragically
and in a way that uh
makes me really emote for dave clyman so
he seemed seemed like a hell of a guy
but uh
he's no longer with us what would you
say if we were reading this list and
your name popped up
what would you want to be known for
others say about our buddy kurt here i
think people that know me in real life
know that uh you know i'm the guy you
can call it 2 a.m in an emergency and
and people who know me know they can
sleep on my couch or that i'm good for
uh
good for all kinds of nonsense when
people need uh need someone to help them
through their their their personal stuff
uh my enemies people who don't know me
will say that i'm for sale and i'll say
anything that i you know
will earn me a buck but uh
as you guys can see i i say what's on my
mind i say
what i think about powerful people and i
think it's crucial to know what you
believe and why over and above what you
do not believe and why you don't believe
it and be be happy to talk about it by
the way if you said you got that couch
hopefully it's a big couch because if
anybody here called you it we would it
would work i'm a big guy so i have a big
house oh that's good okay so let's get
into some of these stories so jack
dorsey first one twitter ceo stepping
down uh officially steps down with his
role effective immediately dorsey
co-founder twitter with evan williams
bistone and noah glass back in 2006 and
served as a ceo until 2008 he later
returned to the ceo role in 2015 and
former ceo dick costello stepped down he
has a net worth of approximately 11.8
billion dollars there's a lot of talk
about the importance of a company being
founder-led dorsey sent an email to
employees ultimately i believe that
severely
limiting and a single point of failure
i've worked hard to ensure this company
can break away from its founding and
founders
dorsey will be replaced by twitter cto
parag agarwal
your thoughts on this move taking place
yesterday
so i think dorsey's hated that company
for about 10 years now why do you say
that
why do you say that i mean he's at odds
with the company like here's the thing i
said before he's a communist who thinks
he's a libertarian and so he's got this
major conflict and that you know he
quotes mises and talks about bitcoin but
but ultimately the the behavior of
things like it's one thing to be
you know hey let's let's let's talk
about sound money and then but actually
i've got this platform that's known for
its political censorship and and and for
doing what the the communist party in
china asks for when when necessary and
and these different things and it's like
if you don't behave the same on friday
night as you do on sunday morning then i
don't like you as a person fundamentally
in fairness not that i i make you know
not that i want to be the guy defending
jack dorsey here but if you believe what
joe rogan has to say he's been
advocating for free speech on twitter
and he's been overruled by his own board
for years so much so that he tried to do
a spin-off called like twitter dark or
something like that where it was
basically going to be a you know twitter
and 4chan where anything goes free
speech up voting system
um and he was again
he was denied by his board so i mean if
you believe that story this is a guy
who's been eaten by his own success he
doesn't even have to say in his own
company
i don't know man when you're the captain
of a ship you
if the ship gets out of control i think
that's your fault like at what point
were the decisions made that allowed a
bunch of nasty social justice warriors
to be in charge of the whole company
like these these are a lot of little
decisions that led to that at some point
and so i think he's got to own that and
and i really i think that's a lot of lip
service because i think in theory he
doesn't want to lose his street cred as
like the cool guy with a nose ring
silicon valley right it's just the whole
thing it's like well i'm going to be
this this disruptive libertarian guy but
i'm also very san francisco and
everything else and it's just it just
they can't be both and he didn't choose
so he's he's been riding the fence for a
decade trying to make twitter outside of
twitter he has a chance to make it right
though
which i i i'm excited for jack dorsey's
second act if if he can come out and do
what he wanted to do if there's a a
chance to do a secondary
you know social media channel that that
promotes free speech he can he can save
his legacy
and we'll see i don't know
the thing that he pretty much put out
there and i my question is how big of a
concern is making money to him or
increasing his net worth because i think
his net worth is what 12 billion dollars
somewhere on that and he said that he'd
want his sole focus now to be on square
and obviously
everything that square is doing in the
crypto space and it's going to be backed
by bitcoin
and
i mean he
twitter i think is down double digits
percentages here he looks at someone
like zuk who's worth over a hundred
billion dollars they're up 20 this year
and he looks at square and says that's a
better opportunity to make more money
how much of a motivation it is to
basically increase his net worth i it's
hard to know i i think square
uh you know square's a big proponent of
the lightning network and and the whole
btc narrative they're part of what's
called the crypto open patent alliance
which i think is another nasty cabal of
people that just want to control things
similar like connected to the barry
silbert people and all of this like
there's a group of people that want to
again pretend that they're disruptors
pretend that they're libertarians
pretend that they're going to do all
these big things and ultimately it's
like yeah but everybody behind me like
yeah i'm going to lunch with world
bankers and and doing all this other
stuff and really
it's i i think it's a larp i think the
whole thing is like look man i'm cool
you can you can use square and pretend
it's bitcoin and and all this stuff like
but keep using square here it's
i think it's a money all of our
employees are going to have critical
theory training and yeah exactly right i
have a question for you so let me tell
you let me tell you what i just did
right now while you guys were going out
i was doing a little bit of research hey
can you uh uh pull up this article type
in jack dorsey says trump's twitter ban
was right decision this is an npr
article i want to read this to you and
then i want to answer a question about
what you said and what you said
that you guys uh made me think
trump's through most uh
donald trump from uh paris
nice great boy yeah right there all
right so check this out so you just said
you just said
uh you brought up uh uh uh you know him
uh you know he's the captain of the ship
he's got this option all this other
stuff and you said rogan et cetera et
cetera he says look i'd love to have
some kind of a second option you know
twitter and i remember when that
conversation took place
uh what percentage of twitter do you
think he owns
i don't even know i want you to guess it
i want you to guess what percentage do
you think he owns if i had a spit ball
i'd probably say 20 or 30.
what do you think he owns i'd say a
little less than that okay so here's
what i want you to type i want you to
type jack dorsey
total shares of twitter and look what
comes up you guys are all going to be
show shocked
jack dorsey total shares of twitter okay
twerk twitter twitter there you go ready
22 million shares which is only three
percent of twitter three percent he's a
nobody
so here's what this means when you're
three percent okay steve jobs got fired
even though he owned most shares when he
got a board the board is a board you
ain't got nothing you listen you you can
be whoever you are so for us to go that
position i don't think he has as much
influence as you think he does to do
what he did with trump or all this other
stuff he may have an opinion i don't
think it's a good idea but the board is
gonna i'm in these board meetings all
the time and believe me i kind of know
how these things work so now go to the
other article what he said about trump
so
so jack dorsey was uh says trump's
twitter ban was right decision but
worries about president so go down and
see what he tweets out he says i do not
celebrate or feel pride in heaven
to ban uh donald trump for twitter or
how we got here after clear warning we
take the uh this action we we the board
made a decision with the best
information we had based on threats to
physical safety both on and off twitter
was this correct and he opens it up and
people are going back and forth yes no
maybe whatever now
deep down inside did he want to take him
off or on i don't know uh did it make
sense to do it or not i don't know
was most of his board probably an
anti-trump board i would be willing to
bet 99 of the board can't stand trump i
don't think they're going to have a you
know for example kellyanne conway sits
on twitter's board that's probably not
going to be happening anytime soon or
ted cruz or any of those guys right so
is there a part of it where
you know
the guys got a difficult job they
started a company that to be honest with
you it's probably one of the most
powerful companies that determined
elections uh you go immediately to find
out what debates are taking place issues
taking place immediate reaction it's a
very very kind of pulse of america right
i don't know i mean it's a pretty
powerful company you know trump wouldn't
become a president without twitter take
twitter out trump's not the president
just so you know that yeah if twitter's
not there trump's not the president and
hillary clinton's the president so for
the people that hate him as much as they
do you may want to thank twitter because
without twitter there is no trump
hillary clinton would have been your
president that's one part now what he
does next i don't know uh you know
whether he is a communist whether he's a
libertarian i have no idea uh what next
moves he's going to make i i i
the real question now becomes who's the
next guy taking over and who sits on
twitter's board can you pull up who sits
on twitter's board well it's interesting
that you say you know that uh he was a
nobody too because his first time on
rogan it was really off-putting i forget
her name there was a woman very very
intelligent woman but it was very clear
that she knew the day-to-day operations
of what was going on behind the scenes
and the decisions being made and he
didn't he kept deferring to her to
answer rogan's questions okay so because
he wasn't the ceo for like five all
right so check this out so here's the
board of twitter brett taylor
independent board chair president and
chief operating officer salesforce okay
cool so that's from salesforce
salesforce is mark benihoff mark
benihoff bought time magazine uh that's
an anti-trump guy that's a liberal left
side
agrawal we know what position he's at
now and where he was at politically he
is not necessarily the biggest supporter
of freedom of speech i don't know if you
guys seen what he tweeted out about
freedom of speech have you seen what he
said about freedom of speech he uh he's
conflicted with freedom of speech he
doesn't think it needs to be
as open as possible you may want to pull
up his name type in perak agrawal tweet
freedom it's kind of not a gray area
conversation you're either for freedom
of speech or you're not freedom of
speech tweet
speech tweet uh pull that up so this is
the board okay go
uh runs on one set the company okay
there you go click on that one right
there fox business the bottom uh uh he
says one set
uh not to be rounded okay keep going up
keep going up keep going up uh uh
uh go up a little bit higher until we
find a tweet uh okay
all right go back and just go to images
go back and type in images it'll come up
if you type in images
if they are not going to make a
distinction between muslims and
extremists then why should i distinguish
between white people and racism that's a
little bit concerning by the way right
so click on that click on that click on
that that's a little bit concerning if
they're not going to make a distinction
between muslims and extremists then why
should i distinguish between white
people and racist so the verdict is
still out we don't know who this guy is
anyways the board chose him
jack dorsey did not choose him the board
chosen now jack says in his email this
was my first option as well this is who
i wanted he's my first round draft pick
go back to the board of twitter i'm
actually just curious right now at this
point on who sits on the board so then
you got mimi senior vice president uh
private um partnership at mastercard
okay cool jack dorsey got it which by
the way in may he's stepping down from
the board as well
uh co-seal at silver lake you know i'm
jefferson lucky voice group former
co-founder managing director last minute
who got it um former his executive
former executive chairman of twitter
cole professor at stanford makes sense
good university general partners
china by the way
who's that faithfully makes sense ceo
for someone with inc
former chairman board of directors at
alliance bernstein hold income okay so
that's who how many people in total uh i
think it's it's either nine or eleven go
up let's see one two three four five six
seven eight nine it's nine okay is there
how many is important to distinguish
between nine versus eleven versus seven
does it make a difference three five
seven nine eleven thirteen fifteen it's
it's whatever the odd number it's always
an
somebody give uh 97 of their company
that's like that's that's if you keep
raising a lot of money well you have to
know here's a question for you what is
the business model for twitter to make
money you actually think how many times
have you spent money on twitter it's
only advertisers yep okay so you have to
know the business model isn't really a
business model like assuming they're
selling information you need a lot of
money they paid a lot of money so data
the new currency to sustain like what do
you think youtube was sold for do you
know what youtube was sold for no it's a
billion dollars seven wasn't i thought
it was more one billion dollars it's a
big billion dollars so because youtube
eventually got so big where the guys
didn't have advertising figured out you
don't have capacity for servers it keeps
crashing so you're like dude i'm gonna
go raise some money you can't afford to
do this anymore so i'm not surprised
he's worth three percent so
jack dorsey is not as influential as
people think within twitter community
that's the point i'm trying to make with
the bigger lesson is the the founder is
not as influential as
as you would assume depends on what
phase at one phase it really depends it
depends on the company structured why it
grew into what it did then this is this
is why i would i would again put the put
the pressure back on jack dorsey though
and say hey man the company looks the
way it looks because of your executive
leadership over the last 15-ish years
you know like that's
again
like russell brooke has never sold a
drug in his life but he created a
platform where people sold drugs at arms
and now he's spending the rest of his
life in the chat yeah nobody's saying
the onus isn't on him yeah you know like
yesterday i'm talking to jack carr i
don't know if you know what jack carr is
the navy seal who wrote all those books
new york time bestsellers and i asked
him a question i said okay so we talked
about afghanistan i said here's a
question for you i said take the general
the army the general air force the
general marines did you take all the
main generals of whatever the four
branches are that we have right
and the president commander-in-chief
says let's get out of afghanistan okay
you're on the ground and you're saying
this ain't the right strategy right
there's no way this is the right move
we're making we're going to leave all
this [ __ ] to the taliban they're going
to come and ruin people's lives here in
afghanistan 20 years we've been working
here i follow orders i said but here's
the question no no that's not the
question the question is
those
nobody becomes the general of the army
marines air force or navy and you don't
have a strong personality
nobody and by the way the general of any
of these organizations it's not like
you're a yes man person right let me sit
there and say hey i'm sorry guys this is
a shitty strategy
i'm gonna have to push back hey
president this is not a good move i'm
telling you my suggestion is we do this
right there's got to be pushback you're
there you know more than the president
does you're trying to tell him he's not
the right move right okay so
but the president says what here's what
we're doing to me
this becomes like who is really running
a company on twitter is it the generals
running it in this instance if you see
twitter's interview with jack and
the other lady that was there it seemed
like the operator operators are running
it jack's not really as involved he was
more the figurehead so sometimes you're
more distant you no longer have the kind
of influence that you had you just kind
of are there on the board because you
have certain special information that
maybe others don't have but you kind of
like listen
it's cool jack and jack's more saying
what do you guys think what are you
guessing what do you guys think rather
than what to do so i don't know i don't
know how much of it is him running it i
think this was kind of coming uh it'll
be interesting to see what this guy does
next he's definitely not going to be
going away i don't think but we'll see
anyways
let's go to the next story here uh you
guys saw what mr beast did i don't know
if you saw that on a youtube star mr
beast created a real-life squid game set
and had people compete for 456 000
which is ridiculous if you haven't seen
this video within four days the video
got a hundred million views in four days
now here's a budget that they have can
we play any of it no no we cannot no we
cannot youtube star mr b shared his
recreation of squid game which included
full-scale sets you can put up the
images so people can see it costumes
that look just like the ones in the show
and a total cost you ready three and a
half million dollars to create the exact
set oh yeah this is a squid game netflix
most watched show of all time is a
korean drama series about a group of
morally gray characters who took part in
children's games and deadly twists in
order to win enough money to pay their
debts everyone in this video game wore
costumes inspired by the show including
mr bees who was wearing the game masters
black clothing mr b said three and a
half million dollars was spent on a
real-life squad game which was partly
sponsored by video game brawl stars he
said on that he spent around two million
dollars to build and produce a 1.5
million on prices for the recreation fyi
you saw the tweet uh kai sent us to us
yesterday he said squid game got some 85
million viewers that watch it on netflix
or whatever it is he said
mr b's got 20 million more viewers yeah
than the show did it's trending towards
craziness when you think about that what
are your thoughts on that
i think mr beast is he knows his
audience probably better than almost
anybody in the space he's incredible at
understanding his audience and he has a
great team around him that's able to you
know capitalize on the moment you would
think like you know squid game when you
do these kind of meme things you got to
be like right off the way we were like
because squid game was a story weeks ago
but for him to do it it was also the way
that they pulled it off if you watched
it was incredible man i mean like did
you watch his videos yeah it was
incredible i haven't seen it also i'm
gonna state for the record squid game
remarkably overrated
communist propaganda anybody old enough
to have ever seen uh you know running
man understands the concept i mean this
was but but that's nothing here there mr
beast you are indeed a beast incredible
now my big question becomes from uh from
a philosophical standpoint i don't know
i i i can say i can say we're going off
the air safer off the air but why how
much money do you think he made off of
that 150 million viewers and it's better
to have a subscription model with paying
viewers as opposed to an ad revenue
here's that's a great question and we
can kind of transition that into mafia
states of america this is what most
people don't understand when it comes
down to youtube and adsense right so
what he produces is a hundred percent
qualified for adsense which means what
per million views he'll make
you know eight to twelve thousand
dollars because probably a lot less to
be honest with you because the heavy
heavy demographic the demographics of
his worldwide audience the cpm is gonna
be way less well but in us let's just
see so let's just say it's seven
thousand dollars put it at seven
thousand per million views yeah seven
thousand dollars per million views
here's the thing way less than people
think by the way say say we do mafia
states of america what do you think the
adsense is on that
what do you think the adsense is on that
nothing do you know why
who the hell wants to advertise a coffee
company on a mafia uh you know killing
each other i killed 19 people yeah you
know what pfizer's going to endorse
their vaccine on our video you know oh
ford is going to come and advertise that
is the part where people don't realize
how adsense works he's got an adsense
machine going on right now he's crushing
it doing a great job adding more power
to him love seeing what is taking place
i spoke at a school
two weeks ago or whatever was veterans
day i don't know what veterans day was a
couple weeks ago i can't tell you how
many kids today who are eight nine 10 11
12 years old say what do you want to be
when you grow up i want to be a
youtuber i can't even tell you can you
imagine us growing up what do you want
to be when you grow up i want to be a
cat guy you know what do you want to be
when you grow up
i want to be whatever today i want to be
a youtuber so that leads me to adam's
favorite story which is very important
for us to cover
woman allegedly breastfeeds cat on delta
airlines okay
yeah by the way this is not a satire
story
this is not i thought
i thought we agreed not to pat i thought
we agreed not to cover the madonna story
fyi this is a newsweek story yeah this
is not onion this is not like babylon
beat this is newsweek credible newspaper
woman on recent delta airlines flight
allegedly began breastfeeding her cat
a pet mid-flight and refused to stop
after getting caught the image
circulating online describes by the way
can you pull up this image uh the
supposed event in what appears to be a
screen capture of a message sent u.s
aircraft communications addressing the
reporting system which pilots used to
transmit short text-based messages to
the ground the message reports that a
passenger in c-13a's breastfeeding
cannon will not put
in response to a request from a flight
attendant the message asked that the
situation be addressed by the airline's
redco team upon landing delta describes
a members of the team as elite airport
customer service experts who are
specially trained to handle on-the-stop
customer issues and now how do you train
this how do you say well guys if you
ever let me explain how that works
how do you trade this
let me take it over from here buddy how
do you train this
uh this is the type of lady that i meet
at the cat conference that i go to when
i was in here somebody find this girl by
the way and there's somebody find this
girl all i want to say she was in 13 a i
wish i was in 13 b
we would have we would have had some
we'll throw some covers
some emotional moments it would have
been it would have been a wonderful
moment
this lady is a hero and she's being
scorned and shamed in public when she's
just trying to feed her damn cats
she lives in flight
not long enough
[Laughter]
so there's your story you wanted it we
covered it thank you are you happy yeah
now let's cover lebron
now let's cover your lebron story
lakers lebron james gets pacers fan
ejected and returned from suspension
which uh you know what a sweetheart of a
guy lebron is uh this is a new york post
story lebron james just can't stop
getting ejected from games this time two
fans
in his first game back from his one game
suspension for bloody and pistons
forward isaiah stewart lebron had a
couple of pacers fan ejected from los
angeles win wednesday night in
indianapolis uh lebron brought the
referees over to two fans sitting
courtside again uh bridge field house
and angrily pointed at them yelling this
one right effin here the fan a young man
and a woman were then asked to leave
with two minutes and 29 seconds left and
over time when upsing gestures and
language come in
come into it it cannot be tolerated
there's a difference from cheering for
your team and not wanting the other team
to win and things i would never say to a
fan and they shouldn't say to me so this
is lebron saying that adam i'm going to
go to you first since you're a die hard
lebron fan i'm not a die-hard lebron fan
i do respect
greatness you know heavy is the head
that wears the crown no disputing there
okay so you know
best player of all time top two okay i
got jordan and lebron i got him then
maybe you've got kareem in there
that's me
but
in my opinion
i don't even know the story with sabonis
i mean you would have him in your time
greatest passing big man of all time
thank you for that jersey but here's the
deal how many lebron gets hated on
like how much [ __ ] do you think has
talked to lebron from the stands every
single game yeah the fact that he ran up
on these two people courtside yeah
pointed them out and full on these two
these two
how bad of what how bad was it what they
actually can i ask you a question yeah
okay here's a question for you all right
so how much of it is self-dep how much
of it is self-inflicted how much of it
is just fans being fans i mean i've been
to games where you're hearing people
calling out fans non-stop in the ugliest
ways right so one
how often do you hear a story like this
about steph curry you don't
how often do you hear stories like this
about mike trout you don't he's um he's
the best player in mlb how many times
are your stories like this about i don't
know pick the name of whatever how many
times you heard the story like this
about ronaldo how many times have you
stored
a story like this about pick any of
these stories sure okay so then here's
what the next thing i say to you is in
the last 40 how are you 40 uh 40 40
years old okay about to be 41 on
february 4th which
is like 41ish but 40 right now so how
many times in the last 30 years of
watching basketball
you've been watching basketball for how
long 30 years my whole life
last 30 years who have been the face of
the league last 30 years is it jordan
kobe and shaq and
you had
since the 80s you had bird and and magic
for sure then jordan took over
then you had kobe shack okay allen
iverson was a facebook league for the
court for they didn't want him to be the
face of the leader but he was yeah he
didn't want to practice that was a
problem we're talking about practice so
we're good so uh and then you had some
dirk for a hot minute you had some you
know the heating over the face of the
league just wanted a hot minute
i agree he was an underdog won the
championship
i loved what he did when they were
come back here so here's the question i
wouldn't vote for trump
best mean by the way by the people
here's a question for you which face of
the league have you ever seen go up to
reference to take the to take these two
guys out okay well let's just get right
into the comments what's been said let's
just say what the comment was which who
said that that was said well
listen okay at some point you're just
gonna have to believe
what do you think okay even if
let me just get this off my chest yeah
allegedly the couple and then it was the
girl that gave the little pouty face
she said i hope your son bronnie james
dies in a car accident
good luck shooting your free throws
buddy so what okay but at some point you
as a father you as a father of two kids
at some point you suck [ __ ] you doesn't
it just rolls off your back you st you
now you want my kid to die in a car
accident
he's heard it so many times adam and and
okay
hear me out at some point though
at some point people have to learn dude
like some of the likes the comments that
people make online and they just go
their little keyboard warriors and they
just go off to regular you know normal
work and they just blaspheme whoever
they want at some point you have to pay
a price for talking stones may break my
bones but he's worth a billion dollars
so the freaking so he can't have
feelings no he's not he's got him but
the thing is he's a robot he's a robot
poor lebron i hope he recovers the thing
about him is now everybody in the world
knows he's listening to what's being
said right he just made it a thousand
percent worse on himself that every
chirp that he's always heard now people
know he's hearing him he's listening to
him it's the worst thing i got news for
you buddy people got ears and if i say
hey kurt you're an absolute piece of
[ __ ] you're going to be like yeah bro
right here in front of you like what are
you doing on an infant
like we have 11 years old human on an
infinitely smaller scale i played minor
league baseball 10 000 people oh no no
you lebron you and the minor leaguers
hear everything they're saying you hear
everything they're saying toshi nakamoto
is jesus and you and played in front of
fans dude same exact thing i get it you
heard when you were sitting on the bench
at community college football you heard
what these people were saying about you
bro you but you have to and i said these
two right here they gotta go
i gotta i gotta i got something in two
minutes so make your point where the
point is this one you either let it go
completely or to your lebron james and
you have something funny to say where
it's like he won't get an accident
because i can afford drivers like or
something like that you you think that
people didn't say this crap to kobe you
think they didn't say
spike lee and reggie miller for people
that are younger and don't know what
it's like to talk [ __ ] look at what
reggie miller did with spike lee with
the new york knicks in the playoffs all
these years spike lee was saying
everything you possibly could reggie
would hit the three and go right up to
him and say that one's for you [ __ ] and
that's how you play it is i played back
i played football but you can all go in
the referee
all the [ __ ] you want these people okay
the most horrifying thing so here's my
question for you
is there anything that anybody could say
that is grounds for dismissal to be
kicked out or anything they could say is
fair player is there anything that
somebody could say to say
stones bro
nothing if they called him the n-word
then
if they did that you would hope that
somebody else would take care of it but
if they don't who cares it's a word as
soon
as soon as they as soon as they touch
you it's on but words lebron james needs
to be protected from words now
words it just makes them look soft i'm
not a big basketball fan but i saw that
it was like ooh
like this it's just lame it was not a
good look it's just i'm not saying i'm
not saying that he should have done it
but i'm saying at a certain point it's
crossing the line it shows you father
and it's going to invite more you get
you get a lot of [ __ ] talking to you you
know
you get a lot of [ __ ] comments stupid
[ __ ] online everyone's tough behind
twitter everyone's tough on youtube
they're the toughest people in the world
youtube commenters but at some point
if someone says something about senna
at some point you're gonna be like hold
up what like as a father how do you
respond to this okay so who's so basic
anyone anyone's fan that's not how life
works that's how life works how would
you interpret if you say it
this is done we have a problem because
you are in the circle of course i have a
problem with you you're not going to
like it if you say anything like that to
me if you say it if a guy off the street
says it what do you want me to do
if a guy off the street says i had a
couple choices i can whoop his ass
i can get him to make a few calls and
make that guy's life a living sammy okay
i can do all of that yeah of course and
if i do that and i go to jail then my
kid's not going to see me for two months
so he caused me to lose two months with
my daughter's life i don't know if it's
worth it but if somebody on the inside
says it it is what it you know we're
gonna have a problem now let me continue
we have something called twitter i don't
know if you've been to that website
there's a guy that was running
this twitter website you know what
things they've said to obama about trump
about anybody you ever gone read the
comments it is brutal right toughest job
in the world
take it if he can't take it i mean buddy
i think listen is that the worst comment
ever made in the history of basketball
no how many times you think people
probably called somebody certain awards
in the 80s 90s and michael still went
out there and won the game so in boston
too yeah i don't know all i'm saying to
you is all i'm saying to you is
this sets the precedence that censorship
is now going into games and sports
period you got to sit there and be like
right you know what i would like i would
i don't like that i would like the
people that made the comment because i
think they did make this comment to have
a conversation when we invite them can
we can we see no get a hold of them no
no let's invite him to the next podcast
sure can you do that and just say how do
you get to justify saying a comment like
this we'll do that to make you feel uh
good about it and then we'll go from
there anyway should they should be held
accountable if they didn't say that
exactly totally i don't think it's
lebron james who should be the guy
i feel you on that but at some point the
[ __ ] talkers by the way they gotta
this is where i come from say i'm in a
place okay guy and a girl are fighting
guy slaps her in the face in the face
guy hits a girl guy hits a girl on her
face unacceptable what i'm saying to you
is i'm gonna do something about it okay
so if somebody around them is sitting
there guys say something like that i'm
gonna be like what what is the freaking
matter with you like in the stands i'd
be sitting next to you saying what is
the matter with i agree are you freaking
stupid i would call your ass 100 we
would have a problem so this is what man
on facebook yeah let the people handle
it so if people around them didn't say
anything
you know dozen four those are the people
that are uh anyways hey uh we don't have
podcast thursday i'm in dallas but i'm
in podcast uh we don't have next podcast
going to be tuesday
uh let's thank kurt for coming out here
where are you thank you for the agree or
disagree this was a lot of fun thank you
thank you thank you uh my man yes can i
can i just say thanks to the the
valuetainers that drove over an hour to
see me on saturday that was 60 people
that came inside from four different
states the valuetainers man two from
delaware two from long island that was
in pennsylvania that was nuts man i love
you guys that was that was really really
humbling that was dope thank you so much
you said you had an announcement on
mafia state no i mean it's just mafia
six comes out friday yeah
announcement 3 99 an episode we don't
get adsense you want to order do so
there's going to be many short clips and
later on our strategy knowing the
direction that youtube is going this is
one thing that most people don't know
about uh last year we used to uh get uh
uh we were doing a lot of interviews on
what do you call it vaccines and all
this stuff we had about 40 to 60 videos
that i've been taking that well let me
comment on that because let me say let
me say this one and i want to hear you
say a couple words on that we had about
40 to 60 videos taken down we have a
completely different strategy on the
direction we're going uh an investment
we're making right now ott long term
mafia states america is going to be one
of the projects that is going to be on
the ott that's the route we're going so
we have to take this route and adsense
is not going to pay for it so for some
people are like you should just put it
on youtube it's going to make the money
back it's not going to make the money
back we would have easily done that so
having said that go ahead yeah so i i
saw i saw the podcast the emergency
pockets they did while i was sitting in
on on the plane man that was very simple
yeah it got along very well but then i
read the comments and and i got i got to
tell i love the valuetainers and i don't
think a lot of those people that were
making those comments are valuetainers
because
here's the thing
as somebody that's watched every single
second and was there for every single
second of this thing being shot
there are things that are going to be so
newsworthy in this there this is history
being made and there is no way youtube
would let it sit
i i all i can tell you is that there's
no way especially episodes four five and
two can't even tell them what it is
especially episodes four five and six
yeah
the last one last one they
there's no way youtube would let this be
you think you youtube would have taken
it down i'm telling you
i'm telling you as somebody if people
have been following me for years no i've
been shadow banned you saw it you didn't
believe me and i showed you it oh yeah
what did it look like i don't know what
you're talking about yeah exactly so the
the
i'm telling you as somebody that that's
been if you guys want this to be real if
you want the pbd podcast you want people
like patrick adam myself to be able to
hold a mirror up to the powerful until
they cannot help but see what they've
become you guys got to support us in
this way and that and and the way that
you support us is by giving us the power
to have a voice outside of them where
they could shut us down so it's bigger
than the product pad to be honest it's a
great product and it stands alone but
it's bigger than that we need your
support so that we can continue speaking
truth in this time of heightened
sensitivities and heightened censorship
you know you made a great point and i
will tell you the true believers of
valuetainment they're all in the true
the messaging and the notes we've gotten
and the amount of people that have
already ordered it yeah they're all in
friday release 8 am first thing in the
morning
i can't wait to see those who binge
watch all 10 episodes and we follow it
twitter mafia states america on friday
we will release
three of the chapters on valuetainment
so you guys will get a chance to see it
and there's going to be a bunch of short
clips free that will be out there but
everything's going to drive back to
mafia states of america you can order
all 10 episodes for 3.99 a pop which is
39.99 have a great week everybody happy
thanksgiving we'll do it again next
tuesday take care bye bye bye bye thank
you